republicans tearing into president biden
over his response to the massive cyber
attack on the colonial pipeline
new video showing long gas lines in the
south and
there are reports of places running out
of fuel russian hackers are being blamed
for the attack
but president biden says there is quote
no evidence
that vladimir putin is involved so dana
i guess he's a smart guy president biden
is good not to get ahead of the
intelligence no tweeting no panic but
at what point do you say yeah if it was
a russian gang
uh we don't doubt that vladimir putin's
behind it
well yeah obviously there's a lot to
uncover there in terms of the
classified information or what other
sort of intel he's getting but one thing
we do know is that this group darkseid
has
never once attacked a former soviet bloc
country
and so you know if you have a criminal
gang operating
out of your country or your territory do
you have some culpability
i would assume that would be the same if
it was happening
here under us and as to the gas
shortages you know
um we've been talking for a long time
about
what do we need to be prepared for in
terms of the next war on
next stage in the war on terror and you
can't say that america has not been
warned about cyber hacking
we know that um or uh countries like
north korea
iran russia are very good and very
sophisticated they have their state
sponsors of this kind of thing
um we i think need to do some sort of
major
hiring push to hire a lot of kids that
want to come and work
on behalf of the country just like they
did after 9 11 and signed up in the
intel community
or they joined the military right now we
need their expertise because this is the
next stage of the war
we've got to be prepared to fight it
so greg is this an act of war absolutely
it is terrorism in an act of war
and i always talk about incentives and
disincentives and a disincentive for
this is to seek out these people
and kill them i assume that we will be
able to find them
because they found out so i think that
that immediately they should be
tracked down and they and they should be
executed um
i do feel though that we i feel like we
are living in the 70s
we have a gas crisis we have a middle
east crisis
we have terror we have inflation we have
gas lines
it's basically like 1976 but we have the
internet
it's like death wish but with
smartphones it's very it's very
depressing at my age to see that
i thought we got out of this but
whenever you get a democrat back in
power you get
all the problems that that come with not
understanding human nature
so jesse do you think that putin is uh
responding to the biden sanctions and
saying hey you know what
russia can hit back at you the united
states and hurt you mr biden
i do because these criminal
organizations they they don't act
without tacit approval from the kremlin
organized crime in the kremlin overlap
and for biden to say it wasn't russia
it was just a bunch of russian hackers
operating within russia
like imagine if trump had said that
rachel maddow's glasses would have
exploded
out of her face so i would recommend the
us respond
another cyber attack counter-attack
against
maybe rosneft the oil company in russia
with ties to putin
secretary of defense waters that's his
recommendation but biden's been
kind of in denial domestically too he
says there's no fuel shortages
uh there's long lines throughout the
southeast there's planes
diverting their flights to refuel
and like what 17 states declared a state
of emergency
i don't know what he's thinking i i i
just got an suv it's like
very expensive to fill up that tank i
have to ask jesse jr to pitch in for gas
money
he doesn't even have an allowance yet
no jesse
uh katie can you hear me
yeah i can hear you i think i've lost
katie katie
oh okay so katie in terms of
this is so go right ahead well i'll just
tell you what i was going to say
i heard that all the guys who could fix
this problem left their jobs for solar
panel manufacturing so unfortunately
they're unavailable to help solve this
problem
the white house today admitted the
energy secretary admitted today
that actually pipelines are the safest
way to transport
oil when i think it was peter ducey who
asked if they were going to bring in
gas from other places uh to make up for
the shortage and she admitted that
pipelines are actually the best way to
go
they just canceled keystone so it would
have been nice to have a backup
pipeline for when one of these pipelines
goes down
but they canceled that project even
though it was an infrastructure project
which they claim that they want to be
putting forward so you know their loss
well i guess we have to look for
infrastructure
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else